♪
>> HOUSE REPUBLICANS HAVE
LAUNCHED A NEW TASK FORCE TO
LOOK AT THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT’S
ROLE AND POTENTIAL CULPABILITY
IN THIS SPREAD OF CORONAVIRUS
BEYOND CHINA’S BORDERS BACK IN
DECEMBER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
>> YEAH, THANKS, GILLIAN, THANKS
FOR COVERING THIS.
GILLIAN: SO AS I UNDERSTOOD IT
THE NEW TASK FORCE IS LOOKING
BACKWARDS, LOOKING AT WHAT
CHINA’S GOVERNMENT KNEW AND WHEN
THEY KNEW IT AND ALSO LOOKING A
LITTLE FORWARD HOW TO HOLD THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT POTENTIALLY
ACCOUNTABLE, IS THAT RIGHT?
>> YEAH, THAT’S RIGHT.
I MEAN, THIS WAS CLEARLY A
COVER-UP AND I THINK YOU WILL
SEE A NUMBER OF GROUPS HELP
UNFOLD WHAT CHINA HAS DONE TO
UNLEASH THIS VIRUS AND NOT
MANAGE IT BUT I THINK WE ARE
ALSO AS YOU MENTIONED LOOKING
FORWARD AND WHAT I LIKE ABOUT
THIS TASK FORCE IS IT HAS
REPRESENTATIVES FROM ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY, ALL TYPES OF RURAL,
URBAN AND OTHER DISTRICTS AND
COVERS COMMITTEES FINANCE,
TRADE, EDUCATION, HEALTH, OF
COURSE, MILITARY, BECAUSE WHAT
CHINA IS DOING AS IT EXPLICITLY
SEEKS TO DOMINATE A NEW WORLD
ORDER WHERE IT CALLS THE SHOTS,
NOT THE UNITED STATES, IS IT HAS
A HOLD OF SOCIETY AND HOLD OF
APPROACH AND THAT’S HOW WE LOOK
TO COMBAT WHAT THEY ARE DOING
FROM THE UNITED STATES.
GILLIAN: ONE THING THE HOUSE
DOESN’T HAVE THOUGH, DEMOCRATS,
HOUSE SPEAKER PELOSI ORIGINALLY
WAS GOING TO JOIN UP WITH YOU
GUYS AND A BIPARTISAN TASK FORCE
BUT SHE LATER RENEGED.
TELL US ABOUT WHAT WENT WRONG.
>> WELL, I DON’T KNOW WHY SHE
RENEGED BUT THIS HAS BEEN --
THESE NEGOTIATIONS HAVE BEEN
GOING ON FOR SOME TIME AND I
THINK DEMOCRATS ABSOLUTELY
SHOULD BE INVOLVED AND THIS IS A
NATIONAL SECURITY AND I THINK
THIS WOULD BE THE NATIONAL
SECURITY MUCH LIKE HOW WE HAD TO
FACE THE SOVIET UNION FOR MOAT
-- MOST OF THE 20TH CENTURY.
THIS WOULD BE THE CASE OF 21ST
CENTURY.
THIS SHOULDN’T BE ABOUT POLITICS
HERE.
TWO THINGS ARE AT PLAY, JOE
BIDEN IS SO BAD ON THIS ISSUE,
HE’S ON RECORD MANY TIMES AS
DOING THAT AND THEN NUMBER 2,
THIS KIND OF NARRATIVE THE
DEMOCRATS WANT TO CRAFT THAT ANY
TIME WE WANT TO DEAL WITH CHINA
THERE’S A DISTRACTION FROM THEIR
PERSPECTIVE OF WHAT THEY BELIEVE
WERE PRESIDENT TRUMP’S FAILINGS.
THAT’S JUST RIDICULOUS.
THIS IS ABOUT DEALING WITH WHAT
I THINK IS THE MOST EXISTENTIAL
THREAT TO THE UNITED STATES TO
LIBERTY AROUND THE WORLD AND
FREE ORDER THAT WE HAVE EVER
FACED.
GILLIAN: SO IS THE TASK FORCE --
I GUESS THIS IS A REALLY
TWO-PART QUESTION, NUMBER ONE IS
THE TASK FORCE PLANNING TO DO
INVESTIGATING OF ITS OWN AND
NUMBER 2, DO YOU HAVE A HANDLE
OF VIRUS AND THE TIMELINE IRON
CLAD, ARE YOU GOING TO PRESENT
YOUR FINDINGS TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
OR WHERE DO YOU HOPE TO TAKE IT
IS THE QUESTION?
MICHEAL: WE WILL INCORPORATE A
LOT OF WHAT THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY IS DOING AND RECEIVE
CLASSIFIED BRIEFINGS AND I THINK
COMING OUT OF THIS IS REALLY
PULLING TOGETHER A NUMBER OF
EFFORTS.
GILLIAN, WE TALKED ABOUT WHAT WE
ARE TRYING TO BRING SUPPLY
CHAINS HOME AND HOW WE ARE
BLOCKING OUR FEDERAL PENSION
PLANS AND EVEN STATE PENSION
PLANS.
HOW THEY ARE TRYING TO STEAL
TECHNOLOGY AND PUTTING
BUSINESSES OUT OF BUSINESS AND
COMPETE WITH US MILITARILY, WHAT
YOU’RE GOING TO SEE IS PUTTING
ALL TOGETHER FOR LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGES AND RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE PRESIDENT.
GILLIAN: YEAH, ANOTHER REALLY
IMPORTANT ELEMENT OF THAT
PACKAGE YOU’RE WORKING ON IS
SEEKING TO HOLD THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY RESPONSIBLE FOR
WHAT YOU’RE CALLING INFILTRATION
OF U.S. UNIVERSITIES, TELL US
ABOUT THE CHINESE EFFORTS ON
THAT FRONT?
MICHEAL: I DON’T KNOW MANY
AMERICANS APPRECIATE.
OVER 400,000 CHINESE STUDENTS IN
OUR UNIVERSITIES AS WE SPEAK
THAT DOESN’T MAKE THEM BAD KIDS.
WHAT THEY NEED TO UNDERSTAND IS
THEIR VICTIMS, THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY FORCE THEM TO
VACUUM TECHNOLOGY, ROBOTICS,
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE AND SEND
IT BACK TO BEIJING WHERE IT GETS
FAST-TRACK RIGHT TO THE CHINESE
MILITARY.
THAT’S ONE PIECE.
THE OTHER PIECES ARE ACTUALLY
RECRUITING AMERICAN PROFESSORS
TO WHAT THEY CALL PROGRAM AND
TAKING HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN INSTITUTIONS AND
RESEARCH FUNDING AND THESE
ADVANCED TECHNOLOGIES AND THEN
GO IN MOON-MIGHTING IN --
MOON-LIGHTING IN INSTITUTIONS
AND WE CANNOT -- LOOK, CHINA IS
LOOKING TO DOMINATE US
TECHNOLOGICALLY AND ECONOMICALLY
AND THEN EVEN MUTUALLY MILITARY
IS IN CHINESE WRITING AND HAS TO
STOP.
GILLIAN: CONGRESSMAN, WE HAVE TO
LEAVE IT THERE.
AN IMPORTANT MESSAGE.
WE ALL KNOW WHOEVER DOMINATES IN
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE DOMINATE
IT IS FUTURE OF THE GLOBE,
REALLY, THANKS FOR BRINGING THAT
TO US AND WE WILL CHECK BACK
WITH YOU SOON.
MICHEAL: I THINK THE SILVER
LINING IN ALL OF THIS IS A